-Let's get to some news here,
guys.
After firing
Attorney General Jeff Sessions,
I read that President Trump
might replace him
with Chris Christie.
[ Audience oohs ]
Christie was so excited,
he tore his apron off
at Jersey Mike's
and yelled, "I quit!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm ready! Let's go! Enough!"
[ Applause continues ]
That's right -- Trump
might replace Jeff Sessions
with Chris Christie.
Apparently, Trump was like,
"The elf didn't work --
let's try Santa."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, get this.
People here in New York
can't stop talking
about a rare Mandarin duck
that showed up in Central Park
a few days ago.
You hear what I'm talking about?
Can we take a look at that duck?
Look at this. Oh, my.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Ooh!
-Ow!
-That is --
That duck is beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
Uh, s-sorry, guys.
Just one second.
I got to do something
real quick.
[ Slow music plays ]
What up, duck?
[ Laughter ]
Couldn't help but notice you
there in the pond.
I just want to say
I like your style.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I new you're new in town
and probably haven't made
a lot of friends yet,
so if you ever want to
just chill and do duck stuff,
give me a quack.
[ Laughter ]
I could come up to the park
and sit on the bench
while you just
kind of float there.
And maybe I could pick up
a loaf of bread
and tear it into little pieces
and throw it at you to eat...
if you're into
that sort of thing.
[ Laughter ]
I-I...
I can tell that you're not like
all the other ducks.
[ Light laughter ]
And...
you may have a mysterious past,
but you've got the look.
[ Laughter ]
So I know this is probably going
to come out all wrong,
but I just wanted to say...
[ Quack ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
-Whoo-hoo!
-Guys, listen to this --
a woman in Australia just
gave birth to a 12-pound baby...
[ Audience murmuring ]
...without any pain meds.
[ Audience groans ]
Her doctor said,
"You were amazing,"
while the baby was like,
"I am never gonna hear
the end of this."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"This is -- I mean,
This is my story now."
[ Applause continues ]
Guys, I'm getting an update
from an earlier story.
I'm not sure
if you've heard this,
but there's a rare Mandarin duck
in Central Park, and...
[ Laughter ]
...it turns out the duck
has gone missing.
-[ Gasps ]
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Oh, my God, I'm sorry, guys.
One -- One sec.
[ Slow music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
What up, duck?
Classic you.
[ Laughter ]
Even when you're on the run,
you got the whole city talking.
[ Laughter ]
You don't
have to explain yourself.
You're wild,
and you were meant to fly free.
And I-I know it's getting cold,
and you're --
you're probably flying
somewhere warmer right now,
as I send this message through
the airwaves,
but...I'll never forget you.
And I hope you don't forget me.
And, hey, no matter what this
crazy world throws your way,
always remember...
[ Quack ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
Hey, guys, I saw that
"The Grinch" is in theaters
this weekend.
I'm excited to have
"The Grinch."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And -- And get this -- they just
added an emotional new scene
where Jeff Sessions reunites
with his family in Whoville.
-Aw!
-Yeah, it's really good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, you guys,
it's time for
"Tonight Show News Blenders."
This is
where we take real headlines
and blend them together
to see how much weirder
we can make them.
I'll show you what I mean.
For example,
if you blend the stories
"Fans Upset After 'Dancing
with the Stars' Elimination,"
"Trump Fires Jeff Sessions,
Quickly Shuffles Staff,"
and "Truffle Season
Doing Well"...
you get,
"Trump Quickly Eliminated
from 'Dancing with the Stars'
After Doing
the Truffle Shuffle."
[ Laughter and applause ]
See?
-Yeah, I get it.
[ Applause continues ]
-Next up,
if you blend the stories
"Under Armour Staff Uses Company
Credit Card at Strip Club"...
[ Laughter ]
..."Ted Cruz Warns of Visit
from Illegal Aliens,"
and "Pop-up Shops Teach
Farm-to-table Cooking,"
you get
"Ted Cruz
Visits Alien Strip Club,
Pops Up Under Table."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
And here's the last one --
if you blend the stories
"Guys Mow 'FU45' into Lawn,"
"Joe Biden Emerges From Voting
Booth, Goes Viral in Minutes,"
and "Bill Gates Says
Toilets Have Chilling Effect
on Environment,"
you get,
"After 45 Minutes,
Joe Biden Emerges From Toilet,
Says, 'FU, Chili's.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's some wild stories.
Guys,
we have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!
-Let's go, man!